una guerra que parece no tener fin este
jueves grupos activistas pidieron a la
asamblea general de la onu la
conformación de un nuevo grupo de
expertos independientes cuya misión
sería recolectar pruebas de posibles
crímenes de guerra cometidos por todas
las partes del conflicto que ha
desgarrado a yemen
todos sabemos que el sistema de la onu
les ha fallado permitiendo una situación
en la que la intimidación y el soborno
la corrupción del sistema han ganado la
partida
[Música]
entre los 60 grupos que hicieron la
petición se encuentra amnistía
internacional y human rightswatch
quienes también acusaron a arabia
saudita y a los emiratos árabes unidos-
de acabar con el anterior grupo de
expertos establecido hace cuatro años
la toma de saná la capital por parte de
los rebeldes útiles en 2014 acabó con la
caída del gobierno reconocido
internacionalmente de abregú mansur al
hadi en 2015 intervino una coalición
liderada por arabia saudita con una
constante campaña de bombardeos aéreos
para acabar con los insurgentes
hay un vacío mortal de responsabilidad
en yemen esto se debe a que el gobierno
saudita mató el único mecanismo
existente el grupo de expertos eminentes
que había establecido el consejo de
derechos humanos extras
se estima que el conflicto en yemen ha
dejado más de 100.000 muertos y unas
cuatro millones de personas han
resultado desplazadas creando lo que ha
llegado a ser calificada como la peor
crisis humanitaria del mundo con
millones de personas sin atención médica
escasez de alimentos y llevando al país
al borde de la hambruna